so this is the airplane for mr. Gaddafi
this was Colonel Gaddafi's most obvious
escape route
blocked by NATO we're come true you are
on the dictators very own first one so
this is one of his chilling areas him
and his cool inside it's first-class
living day later this old the luxury
showers TVs yeah this is for his
security wall a Danna from the brigade
which took the airport a wait last
Friday is proud of his conquest Android
Moos bar is proud of Gaddafi's plane
carefully repairing it for the last six
years what we have is some damages to
the skin of the aircraft and we have
three big holes it is from fragments you
know from the rockets and things so
touches the skins of the aircraft
shrapnel fragments yes his bedroom is in
the front of the plane and with his
luxury bathroom and jacuzzi and
everything yeah and those one of the
Special Forces of Zen tan they are the
first people who entered the airport and
secured very well was it a big fight for
yeah it was indeed it was indeed because
he didn't want to lose the airport
outside on the runway the damage is
evident blamed on Gaddafi who damaged
them who else who else would damage
anything for the Libyans only Gaddafi we
are in the private bedroom of mr.
Gaddafi that's his bed that's so far TV
TV video DVD players every deep
everything to keep him up did
the airport remains closed no one is
flying anywhere but then nor is Colonel
Gaddafi